Shannon we have a list of 10 ways to
generate original movie ideas so number
one is start with personal experiences
and emotions yeah that's a great place
to start and I'd like to
open it up even further to say you know
write what you know right A lot of
people say that and you also know what
the people around you know
right so my personal experiences can
also be the experiences that I was
exposed to because my mother's an
educator so now like if you think about
Abbott Elementary right went to Brunson
said her mom was a teacher so now she's
grown up to be able to write a show
about teaching it's not because she was
a teacher it's because her mother was a
teacher right so being able to start
from things that you know or even things
that you like you know there are some
people who are great researchers right
so if you're a great researcher you can
even start from things that you like
things that you're interested in knowing
about and seeing where that can take you
as well but starting with things that
you already know that you already have
interest in that um like for example if
one of your parents is a doctor then you
might have information about what it is
to be a doctor whether that was because
you were there when they were in medical
school because you have heard stories
about what happens when they're in
surgery Etc all of those are places
where you can draw inspiration from
number two is combine two seemingly
unrelated Concepts or genres yeah this
one's actually my favorite because like
I like I say all the time there aren't
really very many UniQue Ideas right so
what would happen if you decided to take
the protagonist from one thing and drop
it into the world of the other right you
still don't have your goal yet right so
you still have to do some work there
just because you took these two things
don't mean they automatically fit
together right but realizing that you
don't have to start from scratch that if
you really enjoyed the grumpy old guy
from up right what if you put a grumpy
old guy in the um world of
um oh my God it's one of my a quiet
place right now how does the grumpy old
guy survive in a quiet place now I don't
know if that's something anybody wants
to see or wants to watch but it's a fun
place to start to be able to take those
two things and see what kind of magic
you can make if you put them together
number three create a unique world or
alternate universe yeah that goes back
to like our what if we were talking
about with the Sci-Fi channel right so
what if we lived in a world that was
underwater
now you've got a place to start building
from and again all of these that we're
talking about are ideas so always
remembering that you still have to build
the story the idea is this one element
by itself this world where we're
underwater but what we're doing
underwater what we're trying to
accomplish or what we're trying to solve
that's what our story is the world just
gives us a place to start number four
use a familiar story but add a new twist
or perspective so I just talked about
Guess Who's Coming to Dinner right
they've kind of reimagined it with this
uh Netflix uh show not show me movie
called you people right so it's the same
thing uh but it's turned on its head so
instead of bringing a black man home to
a white family it's a Jewish family and
a Muslim family and they are trying to
figure out if these two can be together
right so we kind of know it if you want
to call it a Trope now of what it is to
bring someone who's different home to
meet your parents and what that's going
to do to your relationship right so
we've seen it before so then you ask
yourself well how can I update how can I
make it unique and you might be able to
make it unique by using one of the other
three
um options here right like it's
something that we've seen before but
what if I change the world or you know
what if I take something from my
personal experience and put it into the
story and that's the thing that makes it
unique number five think about societal
issues and turn them into a story yeah
so you can find a lot of theme there
right because we're kind of all living
through the same kind of stuff right so
we all live through a pandemic with that
being said you might be able to tell a
very nuanced story about someone's
personal experience during that time or
even yours something to consider though
is because societal things are kind of
happening to us all then that means a
lot of people may be having those same
ideas right so you still have to figure
out well what is going to make my story
unique from the you know from these
other stories how is the dramatic
question I'm asking different from the
dramatic question that they're asking
but I think that's a great way to figure
out themes
number six take inspiration from dreams
or nightmares ooh that's good if you can
remember them right A lot of people wake
up and they go oh my God I had such a
good thing and then it's gone but if
nothing else at least for me because I
think everybody probably doesn't dream
the same way but I think you can
probably come up with a lot of questions
from dreams like what does that even
mean and then maybe you're solving that
question by writing that story
do you suggest people keep up I mean I
don't know how people would do that but
write something in a little notebook and
then somehow magically fall back to
sleep I don't know how yeah if they
could if they could you know for me all
of my ideas come to me when I'm in the
bed and when I'm tired not when it's
like oh I'm just in the bed and you know
I'll just fall asleep whenever when I am
ready to go to sleep that's when all my
ideas come and that's where my handy
dandy Notes application in my phone
comes from uh comes into handy because I
just keep getting up writing it down and
then I try to go back to sleep and then
something else comes in I get up and I
write it down and I try to go back to
sleep that might not work for everybody
but if you've got a good memory if you
think you're going to still know it the
next morning then don't ruin your sleep
but if it's gonna leave then you need
something right next to your bed a
notebook you know something so you can
be able to write it down and capture
that in that moment that's fascinating
yeah they say that the moment before you
fall asleep is the most when you're most
receptive and a lot of intuitive things
come to you so it's fascinating
and I just thought you were talking in
your sleep Shannon okay no I guess
it was your you were planning a movie
okay number seven use a non-linear or
unconventional narrative structure yeah
that's possible I definitely think if
you're going to do it that way you
should already know what your story is
right so you've got the idea or maybe
you don't maybe your idea is that well
no I think you got to have something you
got to have something that you're
expecting to be non-linear right so
something already exists for you which
is good like knowing that you're telling
a story about whatever and then deciding
what's going to make it different from
other things is the order in which I'm
gonna I'm gonna tell it um because I do
think that that creates something unique
but I think if you're going to think
about the format of it first then there
has to be an it to format so some kind
of idea or story or something is already
present and then you're going to figure
out how you're going to present it
and the thing is if someone wants to
write like the next Memento just really
know like inside and out I don't think I
could ever do something like that
because it's so intricate there's just
all these little you know moving parts
and I'm a linear person so I probably
couldn't help anybody out you know when
it comes to figuring that out you know I
would hope and only again because I'm a
linear person and a literal person I
would need to write it out linearly
first
and then move it around like I would
have to understand it and it's full you
know capacity as one story and then
start putting it in other places
um and for all we know maybe that's what
happened I haven't read the moment of
script you know but for all we know
maybe some people do it that way and it
isn't until the director or the editor
comes in that it becomes this non-linear
thing like who knows but you know I
think it's a great way of telling
stories it's not my way of telling
stories but I think it's a great way of
telling stories number eight tell a
story from a different point of view
yeah that's good too especially when it
comes to you know again going back to
like theme or social or social issues or
subject matter right
um if you consider how someone else
views that thing there's definitely a
story there right it's it's kind of
being a journalist about it right and
viewing all sides and then being able to
say now which side of this story do I
want to tell
um and seeing what you can learn from
there and that's where research will
probably have to come in right because
you're telling it from a perspective
that may not be your own or from a
perspective that we haven't seen you
know very often so you may need to get
some research in there but I think that
that's really cool and it really helps
with theme because it really
um makes your question clear if you're
saying hey this is how you usually see
it or we as in the world right usually
see it but what if we looked at it this
way
what if someone wants to to take the
story from all sides from all parties
involved so there's an inciting incident
and now they're going to tell the story
from all the different perspectives yeah
I think that's possible again as long as
we understand what we're tracking from
each perspective and that it doesn't
just become about theme which I think
you know happens often enough I read
enough screenplays where I'm like I know
you have something to say but because
you're forcing it down my throat I'm
missing the story right like at the end
of the day I'm here to watch somebody
accomplish something big or small so if
I'm going to be seeing the perspective
from five different points of view I
also need to be able to say this
person's point of view or this person
who is in this point of view is trying
to do this and then this person who's in
this other point of view is trying to do
this maybe they're all trying to do the
same thing you know I just need to be
able to track it so that I know
not what the story is about as in what's
the theme because it's obvious that
they're doing it you know have these
different perspectives but I am trying
to track what are they doing what's the
goal what's the problem so that I can
know that if I can know if they were
successful or not you know
number nine experiment with different
time periods settings or cultural
backgrounds that's a great way to do it
all of those things are things that I
would consider the world right and
people do it all the time especially
like with
um you know older uh novels that were
done in the 1800s people will update
them all the time or people will take a
story from now and put it in the future
because we don't know what the future is
going to be right so you get to make it
into something different and create your
own rules
um or if you take something now and
change that cultural background kind of
like we talked with Guess who's coming
to dinner now that we have a Muslim
family and a Jewish family then now
there are other things to consider
outside of race since Guess Who's Coming
to Dinner is based on race now you also
have religion to consider right which is
going to give it a different element so
I think definitely looking at how you
can change up the world and change up
the backgrounds of your characters and
things like that are going to give you
New Perspectives maybe for even a day
old story
and and also too taking older stories
and plugging them into today but also
things around us have changed have
changed so there's a lot more maybe we
think acceptance maybe there's not but
but things are going to be perceived
differently than a story set in the late
60s or 70s versus now exactly so you
have to consider the rules because
that's all work that's all the world
means the world gives you new rules time
period gives you new rules the location
gives you new rules ethnic background
might give you new rules right so what I
can do in California I can't do in Texas
right now in 2023 because the rules are
different right so just imagine if it's
1923 versus 2023 versus 30 23 all of
those rules are going to be different
and that's the thing that's making your
your your idea unique right like uh what
was that Demolition Man I don't know
what time it was supposed to be set in
right but at the end of the day it was
just cops getting a bad guy but it's
different because it's in the future and
the rules are different in the future
and those rules are the things that are
getting people caught up because our guy
is from the present you know uh Stallone
was from the present and so he had to
learn the rules of the future in order
to be able to get the bad guy and that's
what made it a unique story
sure sort of like the precogs or
whatever different things yeah that's a
good point number 10 look at history or
mythology for inspiration and put a
modern spin on it yeah so it's kind of
similar to the world thing right
um but you know take people will often
take historical uh moments and then
change the ethnic background of people
right and that if they're not doing
color blind casting and they're actually
changing the ethnic background then the
story is going to change if they're just
doing colorblind casting as in we're
just going to cast people it doesn't
matter but we're telling the same story
then now it doesn't change it looks cool
but it doesn't necessarily change the
story right but being able to take
something and figuring out how you can
update it or um like what's that that
that movie on Netflix uh it's uh it's
got a good school and a bad school you
could either be a princess or you can be
a witch but that but that's out right
now and it's very you know familiar to
us because we know supposedly all of the
uh fairy tales that we know of come from
there so supposedly Prince Charming came
from this school and so all of these
people who we have learned about in
other parts of our Lives nursery rhymes
fairy tales Etc all have this common
theme of having gone to this school so
the school in itself and these
characters are new to us but because
they are using stories that we're
familiar with then now we're more open
to hearing this story because we feel
like we we're already connected to it
you know so I think that's a great way
of looking at it as well
and two maybe I'm not sure which school
of Good and Evil sorry oh yeah okay
Netflix okay speaking of Wednesday Adams
yeah so that's kind of a a darker Twist
on an older film and you're taking
basically one character I realize
there's ancillary characters but and
then giving it a much more a little more
uh dark sarcasm than right right exactly
and so like it kind of comes back to the
whole established IP thing right if it's
something that we are already familiar
with then maybe we're more willing to
watch this but then you have to ask
yourself but what's making it unique
what's making it different and so with a
lot of reimaginations and reboots and
remakes happening right now that's a big
question like what makes it different
are you literally just remaking the
exact same movie but it's 2023 now so
you've got new actors and that's the
only thing that makes it different or
are you reimagining it by turning it on
its head in some way or is this uh
a reboot where it's the exact same
people and we're just continuing on with
their lives you know what I mean where
we're where wherever it is they last
they last ended and so trying to figure
that out is a little different these
days because we're we're doing a lot of
that we're taking established IP and
making it making it into content um but
looking at books looking at blog
articles I mean all kinds of things you
can get ideas from all over the place
and obviously if it's already been
written before then you have to figure
out how you're going to get the rights
to it but those are all great sources to
start with